we are starting with a concerning new
trend coronavirus cases are on the rise
ahead of the holidays officials report
more than 100 000 cases a day for the
first time since early october however
the cdc says most of the cases are from
the delta variant not the new omicron
strain here is dr frauchi speaking about
omicron yesterday
thus far it does not look like there's a
great degree of severity to it but we
really got to be careful before we make
any determinations that it is less
severe or
really doesn't cause any severe illness
comparable to delta
now the world health organization
reports zero deaths so far from omicron
still rules traveling to the u.s from
other countries are tighter starting
today charlie dagger is in london and he
has that part of the story charlie good
morning
good morning to you those new rules went
into effect at midnight that sent
americans scrambling over the weekend to
make sure that they could travel today
it's not chaos but lots of confusion
before heading back home to wyoming sue
and bill lee had to make an emergency
stop at a london clinic
roughly three or four times in a circle
after the cdc dropped the new rules
about testing
we've been listening to the news news
was saying that the
states were going to up it to 24 hours
we finally got the word that we need to
do it in a 24 hour time we should
mention here they're visiting their son
ian lee london-based cbs news
correspondent
and they say the test itself was a
breeze i mean i was expecting it to be
tougher than it was just from what your
friends tell you but really it was
nothing it was very easy to do
but like other u.s travelers they found
themselves in a hurry up offense after
last week's white house announcement i'm
announcing today
that all inbound international travelers
must test within one day of departure
regardless of their vaccination status
or nationality
that used to be a 72-hour test before
flying leaving americans to wonder where
when and exactly how to get tested we
found out just randomly so now we're
like well
do we wait do we do our test today do we
do it tomorrow it is expensive yeah
especially
to get fast results
same-day results is more expensive so
yeah
now it largely comes down to airlines to
inform passengers of new changes here in
the uk it's relatively straightforward
but it's not cheap you can walk into a
clinic and get the results back around
three hours but it's going to cost you
around a hundred dollars vlad
all right charlie dagon in london thank
you charlie